(dramatic music)
(banging)
(Joyce grunts)
- Don't you dare.
At least I was here!
- Oh, come on, Joyce, just
look around this place.
All your Christmas lights,
what the hell am I supposed to think,
you're such a great mom?
You're a mess!
- Maybe I am a mess, maybe I'm crazy,
maybe I'm out of my mind, but God help me,
I will keep these lights
up until the day I die
if I think there's a chance
that Will's still out there.
Now, get out, get out of my house!
(door bangs)
- Hey, get back inside.
- What, are you insane?
- Look, something happens to
me, I don't make it back--
- Yeah, well then I'll go, you stay.
Are you kidding me?
He's my son, Hop, my son, I'm going.
You took my boy away from me.
You left him in that place to die.
You faked his death.
We had a funeral, we buried him,
and now you're asking for my help?
Go to hell.
Can anyone tell me what's wrong with him?
Can a single person in this room tell me
what is wrong with my boy?
What is wrong with my boy?
We have to kill it.
I want to kill it.
We need to burn it out of him.
This thing has had Will long enough.
Let's kill the son of a bitch.
We have had a very long day.
We have been shot at, nearly blown up,
walked God knows how many
miles in 100 degree heat,
stole a car, all while being chased by
this gigantic psychopath, all so we could
bring him to you, because somehow,
you're the closest person
who speaks Russian,
which I can't believe.
But that doesn't matter, because
unfortunately, we're here.
So if you don't mind, put that thing away,
stop behaving like a jackass, and ask him
what he's doing that's
making my magnets fall
off my damn fridge!
- Ma'am, I'm gonna need you to stay calm.
- No, don't you dare patronize me.
I don't know who you are,
if you're some glorified
secretary or what,
but if you don't wanna lose your job,
here's what's gonna happen.
When I hang up, you're
gonna get up off your ass
and you're gonna go find Owens
and tell him what's going on.
We don't have time to talk about it,
and neither does he.
He's gotta get to Hawkins
and he's gotta bring his men
right now, do you understand me?
- Yes, yes ma'am.
- Thank you, and good day.
(phone slams down)
- Wait, that's right, we're on our way
to rescue our children from the big bad
Fourth of July celebration.
- You know what, if you can't handle this,
then just turn around
and drop me off first.
- What are you gonna do?
You gonna walk back to Hawkins?
- I will do anything if
it gets me away from you.
- Children, children, children!
(circus music)
- Hey, Larry.
- Joyce.
(punch thuds)
(Larry yells)
(kick thuds)
(groaning)
- [Man] Yeah, lady!